I guess that's why I asked because and
I'm trying to work it out of my head as
I asked you because it sounds like you
didn't give up on the idea of being
creative but you just decided to go
another route with it because I know a
lot of people who say you know what I'm
done I'm doing I'm tired this person
told me that I'm no good or whatever and
they won't return my phone calls and so
I'm finished but it sounds like you said
I'm finished to this part but I'm still
going to do something that's creative
and I was just wondering what the
revelation was and it sounds like you
were at a point your life where a lot of
things were going on and yeah willing to
to know that it was time yeah I mean
it's I wanted to do what I'm doing since
I was like five or six years old I
always wondered I always you know I
never understand people who you know
like I i'm not sure what I'm gonna do or
what I'm gonna major in and no insult to
you but I have had a passion for what
I'm doing since I was very young and so
I again it's probably the area
stubbornness I was never going to give
up and I guess there's a huge part of me
that doesn't want to admit to anyone
that that I would that I would have
failed at this so I was that was never
going to be an option um I had you know
there's a number of things that
contribute to this i lost my brother
when i was in college he was killed in a
fishing accident in Alaska and I I
realized that you know this life that we
have can be very short it can be taken
away in a moment's notice and I would
never and I just always think of my
brother talking to me you know in those
moments where I'm like you know you
should give up or it didn't work or you
don't know what you're doing you know
because everyone has those moments the
voice in your head it's like in Birdman
um I mean you know that's why I'm part
of why i love that film so much he
really goes into depth there but yeah we
all have those the voice in our head and
one of those voices that I have is my
brother saying look man you know this
could all be taken away from you
tomorrow and you have to live your life
and be true to yourself and for me that
is you know to stay in this and keep
fighting the fight and
see what I can do I I've already had
such amazing experiences that now I just
want more of that you know now I just
want to keep producing and traveling and
working with the amazing artists that I
get to work with
you